[inaudible].
How good are you at learning languages? Solving puzzles, thinking logically,
and putting pieces together? Well,
this summer there's a competition where you can find out and know it has nothing
to do with the World Cup, mostly
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Every once in awhile I talk myself into learning a new language.
Before I know it,
I'm checking out some course from the library that has me solving problems like
this. What do you mean scow?
Say what you are now feelings. What is it?
What do you say? Um,
what do your ex say? Oh, good job.
But when you get linguists and mathematicians together,
problems look a little different. They're more like this.
The sentences on the left are in Zulu.
The translations are somewhere on the right.
Can you match them before your eyes glaze over and start rolling back into your
skull?
Let me tell you that everything you need to solve that problem is right there in
front of your face.
That's the idea behind the international linguistics Olympiad coming up this
July where this would be one of the easy problems from Basque to bar codes,
bizarre notations to unfamiliar accounting systems,
all kinds of problems that are up for grabs, and it really,
no expertise is ever required other than your own smarts.
Oh, leave a comment to let me know how you guys do.
In the meantime,
I'm off to put some hard work into my regular programming for all you thoughtful
folks who stick around and hit the subscribe button. Stay happy,
keep those neurons firing and thanks for learning with me.